PROFESSOR: We have two
equations now relating
this number of states.
And now you can say, oh,
OK, so I look at the k line.
And I look at the
little piece of the k
and say, oh, how many
states were there
with 0 potential, some
number, first blackboard.
How many states are there
now with some potential,
some other number?
It has changed.
For every-- because these two
equations, the n for equal dk,
the n is not equal
to the dn prime.
In one case, the energy
levels or the momentum levels
are more compressed
or more separated,
but whatever it is,
whatever the sign is,
there is a little discrepancy.
So both of them are
giving me the total number
of positive energy
states in the little dk.
Case So if I take
the difference,
I will get some information.
So I would say the
following, if I
want to calculate the number
of positive energy solutions
and now I think the following,
I take the potential V equals 0
and slowly but surely deepen
it, push it, and do things
and create the potential V of
x slowly, slow the formation.
In this process, I can look
at a little interval dk
and tell how many states are
positive energy states I lost.
So if, for example, dn is
bigger than dn prime, dn equal 5
and dn prime is equal to 3, I
started with 5 positive energy
states in this little
interval and by the time
I change the potential
I ended up with 3.
So I lost 2.
So let me write here the
number of positive energy
solutions lost in
the interval dk
as the potential is turned
on is dn the original number
minus the dn prime.
If that's positive,
I've lost state.
If it's negative, I gained
state, positive energy states.
In this number, we can
calculate the difference.
This is minus 1 over
pi d delta dk dk.
I'll put it here.
We'll we're not far.
We'll this is what you lost.
The number of positive
energy eigenstates
that you lost in little dk.
To see how many positive energy
states you lost over all,
you must integrate over all
the dk's and see how much
you lost in every little piece.
So the number of positive energy
solutions lost, not in the dk,
but lost as the
potential is turned on
is equal to the integral over
k from 0 to infinity of minus 1
over pi d delta dk is in
the way of that expression
of that right coincide.
But this is a total derivative.
So this is minus 1 over
pi delta of k evaluated
between infinity and 0.
And therefore, the number
of states lost is 1 over pi,
because of the sign down to
0 minus delta of infinity.
So we're almost there.
This is the number of positive
energy solutions lost.
Now I want to emphasize that the
situation is quite interesting.
Let me make a
little drawing here.
So suppose here
is the case where
you have the
potential equal to 0
and here is energy equal to 0.
Then you have all these states.
Now even though
we've put the wall,
the wall allows us
to count the states,
but there are still going to be
an infinite number of states.
The infinite square wall has
So that thing really continues,
but what happens by the time v
is deferred from 0?
Here is that the E
equals 0 line and here is
the E equals 0 line.
As we've discussed,
as you change
the potential slowly, this
are going to shift a little
and some are going
to go down here,
are going to become
bound states.
They're going to be a number of
bound states, N bound states,
number of bound states
equal N. And then
there's going to be
still sub states here
that's also go to infinity.
So you cannot quite
say so easily, well,
the number of states here minus
the number of states here is
the number lost.
That's not true, because that's
infinite, that's infinite,
and subtracting infinity is bad.
But you know that you've lost
a number of finite number
of positive energy solutions.
So as you track here, the
number of states must--
the states must go
into each other.
And therefore, if these
four states are now here,
before they were here, and
those were the positive energy
solutions that were lost,
in going from here to here,
you lost positive
energy solutions.
You lost a finite number of
positive energy solutions.
Even though there's infinite
here and infinite here,
you lost some.
And you did that by
keeping track at any place
how much you lost.
And therefore the states
lost are never really lost.
They are the ones that
became the band states here.
So the positive energy
states that got lost
are the bound states.
So the number bound states
is equal to the number
of positive energy
solutions, because there
are no lost states.
So this is equal to a
number of bound states,
because there are
overall no lost states.